وزير الدفاع الامريكيه لويد اوستن عن قلقه
العميق اذا ما وصفه بالتطور الخطير الذي
تحرزه ايران في مجال تخصيب اليورانيوم
وخلال مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع نظره لاسرائيلي
في مطار بن غوريون شدد الوزير الامريكيه
على ان مقاربه الرئيس بايدن لملف ايران
النووي تبقي او تبقى في اعتماد الطرق
الدبلوماسيه لوقفه هذا البرنامج
يعيش
هذا مثال اخر على التقدم الخطير الذي
تحرزه ايران في المجال النووي وانا بالطبع
قلق بشكل عميق ازاحه ان اولويه الرئيس
بايدن بشان ذلك هي استخدام الوسائل
الدبلوماسيه كافه من اجل تقييد قدره ايران
في هذا المجال لذلك نتطلع قدما لمواصله
هذا المسار من اجل التاكد من وقف هذا
التقدم الخطير ومسؤوليتي كوزير للدفاع كما
تعلمون هي ان اوفر للرئيس الخيارات كافه
اذا كان يرغب بذلك
بجانبه قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي انه
يجب الاستعداد للتحرك على كل الصعود لمنع
ايران من امتلاك سلاح النووي واضاف خلال
المؤتمر الصحفي اليوم مع نظيره الامريكي
بمطار بن غوريون ان تمكن ايران من حيازه
سلاح نووي سيزيد من مستوى الارهاب في
العالم حسب تعبيره
من واجبنا ان نتخذ كل التدابير اللازمه
لمنع ايران من حيازه سلاح النووي وفي هذا
السياق فان قدراتنا وتعاوننا يحمل معنى
وتاثيرا كبيرين ان التهديد النووي
الايرانيه يتطلب منا ان نكون مستعدين لكل
المسارات اكرر واشدد على ذلك يجب ان نكون
مستعدين لكل مسار من مسارات التحرك في حال
حيازه ايران للاسلحه النوويه واعتمادا على
قوه الردع النووي سيزيد النظام من انشطته
عبر دعم ارهاب حزب الله وحماس وتصدير
اسلحه الى كافه انحاء العالم بما فيها
طائرات مسيره وصواريخ دقيقه